il était proclamé grand gagnant
sommelier des amériques 2018 en mai
dernier en 2017 il était sacré aussi
meilleur sommelier du québec et une
deuxième place aux nationaux et là il va
représenter le canada aux mondiaux de la
sommellerie en mars prochain en belgique
avec nous ce matin j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir le sommelier pierre-alexis
soulière par ailleurs aussi master
sommelier bonjour et bienvenu merci bien
alors là c'est au mois de mars que ça se
passe ce fameux concours mondial des
meilleurs sommeliers du monde
j'imagine que vous êtes comme un athlète
vous vous entraînez beaucoup alors
qu'est ce à quoi ça ressemble un
entraînement de sommelier d'abord la
compétition ce jour en trois points
théorie pratique donc le service et la
dégustation
donc vous avez travaillé sur ces trois
aspects là et vous entourer de gens de
qualité dans le domaine qui ont des
forces des faiblesses des spécialités
que ce soit dans le monde des bières
dans le monde des vins dans le monde des
spiritueux étudié dans les livres tout
ce qui est géographie sociologie
histoire terroir et aussi déguster
déguster déguster se mettent en
condition se mettant en game shape comme
on dit pour attaquer au mois de mars est
arrivée tout est possible tout est
plausible peut vous pose les questions
sur tout et n'importe quoi précédent à
savoir le plus possible
et puis d'arriver en forme et bien
mentalement surtout et puis surtout
cracher souvent parce que vous aurez
goûté beaucoup de vins combien à peu
près par année à écouter à disons que
vous goûtez au moins dix vins différents
par jour x 5 ça fait 50 x 50 semaines ça
ferait 2520 en moyenne je sais pas au
moins 2020 par année mais vous pouvez
pas tout les boire pour les recracher
faut les tester il faut laisser tout se
passe vraiment dans le ressenti un nom
peut pas tout à fait faire la même chose
avec la nourriture mais avec le vin
c'est facile de faire la rétro olfaction
de recracher d'analysé de prendre des
notes
et puis après de prendre une bonne bière
pour se remettre le palais zahoui pour
réveiller les papilles où les cadres et
beaucoup de personnes parlent de bière
souvent on va parler de pétillant je
pense que le co2 doit remettre un peu le
palais de manière même si vous goûtez
120 par jour à un moment donné vous
allez avoir une saturation s'avoue
devait être focus et sur quelques vins
on a tous des limites
ouais donc voilà parce que les
saumoniers ne faut pas juste parler de
vin est présenti du vin vous êtes aussi
testé sur balles et les alcools et
spiritueux le sac et c'est très vaste
historiquement si vous regardez le
travail du sommeil est un travail de
boissons ont conservé les boissons dans
les très grands restaurants souvent dans
des hôtels
aujourd'hui c'est un travail qui s'est
démocratisée vous le retrouvez dans
différentes sortes de restauration du
bistrot au restaurant plus haut de gamme
au restaurant d'hôtel même parfois dans
certains casse croûte on a des belles
cartes des vins
il ya des tendances donc je pense que si
vous regardez vraiment historiquement
tous les boissons cafés thés aux alcools
et spiritueux de liqueurs apéritifs
aujourd'hui tout dépendamment du concept
vous allez avoir des produits qui sont
punis chez mais quand on parle de
l'international la vision de la
sommellerie internationale c'est tout
les breuvages
alors il ya la théorie bien sûr mais la
pratique fait qu'on voudrait vous mettre
un petit peu à l'épreuve ce matin on
présente donc c'est un verre de vin qui
est noir donc on ne peut pas savoir même
à la lumière s'il est rouge blanc ou
rosé alors en une minute là les îles
décrivez nous ce que vous ce que vous
sentez ce que vous allez ressentir en le
sentant ayant le but vend également le
goûtant la première chose c'est d'abord
on devrait faire le visuel mais là on
peut pas le faire ça la deuxième chose
c'est que vous avez parlé de cracher si
j'aurai un crachoir je cracherais je
verrai la couleur du vin ah oui c'est
d'ailleurs là je ne vois ni peu pour moi
c'est vraiment sur le free blanc c'est
très très très expressif ça me fait
beaucoup plus penser à un vin blanc quel
vin rouge
en même temps il ya ce côté un peu
fraîcheur je ressens et qui est de la
fraîcheur dans le vin donc peut-être que
bons rails et peut-être un crachoir ici
là peut-être qu'on pourrait apporter un
côté un peu épicé également et un côté
fleurs blanches est très délicat et l'
embauche
qu'est ce que ça donne pour moi c'est un
vin déjà si on parle de cause à effet je
verrais plutôt quelque chose sur un
terroir très frais en plus tôt au nord
si on est en europe plutôt au nord de la
france où il ya quelque chose de très
très très quasiment salins très délicat
dans ses villas et beaucoup beaucoup
d'acidité également on n'a pas beaucoup
d'alcool ses traits fins et très minéral
alors évidemment des la question qui tue
c'est toujours se voir qu'est ce qu'on
boit qu'est ce que c'est avec tout ce
que vous venez de décrire ça vous
justement faire peut-être des
projections c'est pas une science exacte
aussi pour moi il ya un bon côté
lactique également dirais que c'est un
vin le raisin déjà sympa beaucoup
naturellement donc on a essayé avec la
vinification qui a ajouté un petit peu
de corps un petit peu de ça me fait
penser à chablis peut-être un chablis
village c'est très délicat ses traits
fins et très bon ben on regarde c'est
effectivement français on n'est plus
dans le nord on va être ici dans la
loire apparemment c'est un sou mur donc
le cépage ces jeunes emelin shauna blanc
voilà donc c'est quand même un courrier
le travail d'analysé sensorielle on va
dire ça c'est assez incroyable
en tout cas on va vous souhaite
évidemment bonne chance à anvers c'est
au mois de mars en belgique absolue
puisque vous êtes là c'est la période
des fêtes de fin d'année on a un
sommelier donc est ce que vous nous
suggériez là qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire comme suggestions de vins là pour
les retrouvailles en famine
moi je crois beaucoup à la saisonnalité
ici au québec il ya quatre saisons qui
sont bien distinctes souvent dans le
temps des fêtes on va manger des choses
qu'on peut plus racoleur un petit peu
plus riches et puis on a des besoins
devant un petit peu plus de soleil je
pense tout de suite au portugal oui à
une maison que j'ai visités au mois
d'octobre qui met quelques j'adore qui
s'appelle crashed au crash ton rock et
sert à st lô
donc il ya un vin qui s'appelle flore de
clash doc et la fleur de cristaux qui
est à moins de 15 $ à la saq qui est
tout à fait délicieux et sinon tu vois
un peu plus monter en gamme pour 18 $
vous allez trouver kinta de crash tôt et
ça pour moi c'est une perle 120 qui qui
en donnent qu'un rapport qualité prix
imbattable à la saq en ce moment puis
les champagnes évidemment pour les 24
coups de minuit bien feu ou à voler g
jona faible pur bonheur bon je me suis
marié à en servant maulin jamais évité
et dans les grandes comme dans les
petites occasions bollinger pour moi
c'est un champagne qui ne déçoit pas
bomber c'est bien noté pierre lexis
houillères master sommelier et meilleur
sommelier des amériques bonne chance
évidemment aux mondiaux merci d'être
venu ce matin
merci frédéric en six jours et 7